i just don't care i had to do a i've
done a million i've done a million
auditions i've never gotten one
and i had to do one where my dad died
next to me on the couch
and they threw me out of the room that
bad oh really
like get out of here doing yeah i was
like oh
dad what are you crazy are you dying on
us
yeah geez louise yeah yeah they're like
all right you're wasting our time i was
like i drove here from santa monica took
three hours
yeah but it's it's weird because they
kind of like your
people call you yes this is a great
opportunity
yes they'll see stuff like that and it
can elevate your
career and it'll it'll translate into
you know i mean yeah
numbers and all that kind of stuff and
then you start thinking maybe i will get
it maybe
it could change my career but mark what
i'm saying to you is is that
all those experiences that you have
everyone goes to that
yeah but you get stuff no but i want to
say this though and
you you can be you know i mean you can
back me up here
is i've been in la since 1999 98
right wow and yes i have gotten a lot of
stuff right
but i've been told no a million times
and i've had ptsd in those rooms
yeah when you sign up right you're in a
hallway with a bunch of folding chairs
you sit there and people who look like
you
people they all look like you they're
wearing hawaiian shirts or whatever it
might be right yeah yeah
and then you're just kind of like they
call your name and you rehearsed it for
two days
yep right and as you stand up it all
yeah yeah it all just it's gone so good
right because you know i mean you and
then you start panicking
yes and then you start unfolding your
sides
on the walk into the room yeah because
you all it all slipped away oh and this
is the jew [ __ ] behind the desk going
she's eating uh she's eating noodles
like all right
38 hundredths guy she saw that day right
and then it's like all the stuff that
you memorized that you knew inside and
out is so gone
that now you're reading it off the page
yeah right yeah and then they're like
you know um
thank you yeah it's over like that it's
over like that you walk
and then there's a feeling when you
leave and you're in your car
that's so demoralizing man did you nail
that
yeah yeah but i'm saying to you i just
got a shitty feeling
because i know that feeling yeah yeah i
know i know and i because i'm telling
you
when you were talking about your thing
is all the things that i've
i've lived through wow at the end of the
day though i have to say to you
that you will get one ah that's what my
agent said
damn it yeah yeah and and when you do
get one
and you show up and you do it and it
comes out okay
you get better yeah and better and
better and then one day
you're going to be in a situation where
you're going to be around with all these
people that you never thought you'd be
working with it gets pretty bad for him
one time he came home and he was like he
had a bloody nose like he was bloodied
up and cut up after an audition
and i was like what what happened he's
like i beat myself up
that's how badly he felt like he beat
himself up with a water bottle
and over and over again because he felt
just so humiliated
did you get it
yeah one time she dragged me into the
thing i beat myself up
and then the call was this because
here's the
deal mark is um okay
um as an actor right you have a group of
guys right and and um like any actor in
la white guy
your type whatever right but as a
producer i go
all right but this guy is green i'm
talking about you
but he has a huge audience right
that helps know who he is right and it's
gonna help
me with the movie so all you have to do
is deliver
something that's either mediocre to good
right right in that kind of ballpark and
then you have a shot
yes you know so it's like when i beat
myself up
they were like he didn't know his lines
he read it off the page
and one of the producers says yeah but
you know he's a funny guy he's like
intrinsically funny and we know
who he is and what he is i think that we
can work with it when he's on set
ah right and you will go through the
same thing
because i've been hearing about your
name for a couple of years now
right but not just in uh oh you hear
about this funny guy no
like he's you know yeah here we go
here's a compliment here can i just just
shut up man oh god
you're gonna take it man hold on let me
put my hand am i yelling am i doing
being too crazy
am i being too passionate i'm sorry
you're fine uh just
i'm gonna i'm gonna no no no
put those back in all right all right i
just want to say this um
pro that um you know i have i mean a
pool of people all right but how about i
just get to that level
and then do the [ __ ] up man instead of
uh
white mouth white people always have to
talk over the ethnics
right true let me so let me just finish
what i'm saying all right and then you
react
react accordingly all right look at me
say i'm cute again
cute look at me
very cute yeah okay there's an old a a
sanic i mean
alcoholics anonymous they say they
always say fake it to you make it
fake it till you make it yeah i've heard
it right so it's like you
you show up like you know i'm i was just
in oklahoma
quit bragging and i did this
this um fx show where i played a doctor
and i was scared of it when i did the
rehearsal ask sterling the showrunner
he was a little scared because when i
did the rehearsal
i was stuttering through every line
because the cast and the kids were there
and the all the cameras were set up
and you know there's 100 people in the
room yeah
you know i'm stuttering through the
thing and what i did was i
started breathing and i and i announced
to everyone
i go i know that that don't be nervous
i know i stuttered and i know i i am
nervous
right but when we shoot i'm gonna kill
it you just have to fake it you gotta
figure and it feels like everyone else
is nailing it everyone else is confident
except you
but they're [ __ ] up too they're not
yeah thank you
that's exactly the thing so are you
going to still audition or no
i'll wait till i get big and then i i
had neil brennan call me that day and
he's like i got something for you and
then i've had schumer give me a thing so
it's like
can i just do that oh
you know i don't have to do the [ __ ]
because don't you feel like you're just
a stack on a pile of tapes or whatever
it is and
no you don't think when i get an
audition i had one
yesterday gilbert came over i put myself
on tape and and it was the second time
for this one thing because it's like
the first time i did it they called and
said it's wrong
wow but that they might not care they
care enough right you do it again it's
wrong we'll give you some
notes right it's absolutely wrong and it
wasn't good
right it was a black guy yeah yeah yeah
wrong role yeah but then gilbert came
over last night
you know what normally i would be like
for me five years ago i've been like you
know it's not for me
there's no way i'm going to get it yeah
but i did it because
i'm going to try there you go i have to
try right
and i think i have a chance here here
and i go into everyone
like that i have to try it's got you
know i mean i know you fart all you want
sorry right
and it's like um you're on a roll keep
going baby
this is good this is your oscar speech
i'm trying to help you
yeah [ __ ] hey [ __ ] face i'm trying to
help you i'm listening it's all good
stuff
i just had a we had a meatloaf where'd
you eat meatloaf
we got into the noho diner over here is
it good yeah
yeah pretty good you know what georgie
yeah big gay scene
hey guys we're gonna take another quick
break to share this awesome sponsor with
you
you guys roman swipes this is the new
deal baby